we've been asking the public with the
help of yougov what they make
of the current situation and this is
what they had to say
two-thirds 67 of people told us they
were scared of the impact of coronavirus
this winter 29 said they weren't
a majority said the uk government is
generally making
the wrong decisions on how to handle
coronavirus
just over a quarter said their decisions
are generally right
and nearly two-thirds 61
of people told us they don't trust boris
johnson
to make the right decisions over the
virus of all the leaders of government
we tested
only nicola sturgeon isn't more
mistrusted than trusted
to make the right decisions now the poll
suggests the british people
aren't in favor of relaxing restrictions
over coronavirus
we asked whether people support relaxing
lockdown measures for
younger people while maintaining rules
for older
and more vulnerable people 26
supported it while 64 opposed it
now what about a circuit breaker
lockdown two-thirds
67 said they would support going into a
strict lockdown for at least
two weeks and lastly the question over
if it's possible
to solve the issue of covert before a
vaccine
is discovered or if it'll only be
possible after that well 40
said it could be solved before a vaccine
43
said only once it's discovered while
just 17
here weren't sure